what's good GQ this is J Park I have my
shirt off again and this is my tattoo
tour let's get
[Applause]
it my mom did not and still doesn't like
the tattoos that I have just because
like I think Korean people they relate
tattoos to kind of like gangsters and
the mob people and so it's like they
kind of correlate that together like
tattoo means crime it's bad like so for
me since I do have a lot of tattoos and
I'm still very active you know I always
have to cover it up with stickers or
wear you know like long sleeve since I
have it on my fingers as well it's like
I have to cut little stickers and put it
on each individual finger so yeah it's
it's a it's it's a process so you know
hopefully one day they'll allow it on TV
and Korea hopefully I kind of open the
doors for the newer
guys at first when I started I got like
little ones the first one is on the back
of my ear the a one that's the first one
then I got lettering here and there um
and then I think I got addicted to it
cuz then then you you start seeing blank
spaces and you're like that looks so
weird like what like and then you just
start filling it up and then yes and it
just eventually it turned into a sleeve
higher music is a label that I founded
in 2017 and I was shooting a video with
this rapper named stupid young you know
that we shooting at a tattoo shop and
they were like yo you want to get a
tattoo while you're filming I was like
all right let's do it the healing
didn't go too well so that's why it's
like a little bit
scarred so I wanted to get a neck tattoo
to I wanted like to get one right here
but then I feel like that would be just
too hardcore and like my mom would
disown me and so I got one right here
and it's like a compass like you know
trying to find direction in life but
also it's like the Mariners logo so also
like got these stars for no reason
that's back when people just getting
hella stars and I was like yo Lil Wayne
has a star so let me get a star so I got
these stars for no reason and then I was
like let me cover it up with something
more meaningful and so that's why I got
the compass is you know finding
direction in life and then I also have
the jwalkers on the on the upper spine
and jaywalkers is like the name of like
my fans cuz um J Park yeah word play I
know genius I know I have a big angel
with the Rings wrapping around my skull
and also it's like you get cover it up
cuz you're hair gross so I was like oh
that's that's very convenient and so
yeah I got a big head tattoo that was
definitely the most painful tattoo yeah
everywhere else was like you know I
could I could just be on my phone and
get it drink Hy and get you know shoot a
music video while getting it this one I
was like the whole like for 6 hours I
was just like
there at least it was just one session
so that that that was helpful and I was
a little hung over so it was like that
didn't help at all so the hands it's
like you know Heart of a Lion M I'm him
you know what that is yeah you're
nodding your
head yeah so yeah I have this line and
the King life it's like you know I take
care of a lot of people it's not like
necessarily like yo like I'm a king I'm
above all of you it's more like yo I I I
try my best to take care of my people
and that's that's kind of what that
mentality is the good life you know you
only have one life so make sure it's
good new breed is the first album that I
made at that time I was a lot younger
and it's like yo yeah I'm the I'm a
New Breed it's like you know that type
of ignorant
mindset so this is just like indicating
I guess my love for music and you know
I'm a singer songwriter so I have a mic
cuz I spend a lot of time singing into a
mic on this side you have Benjamin
Franklin which is on the $100 bill and
then you have loyalty so for me it's
kind of like loyalty over money and
that's another mentality or like
philosophy that I have I got like piece
by piece and then it was at this time
where it's like why does it look weird
because there's like just to me at that
time empty space on my arm looked weird
like what do I need to do and so I I I
looked at a bunch of like other rappers
and other you know actors and models
like how they did it and so they had
like a lot of like filler in between
like shading in between and so I just
asked my tattoo artist I was like yo
like let's try to make it like some like
cloud or smoke or and then so I just I
just got a bunch of shading this is like
a caricature of myself and then on the
left you have Seattle this this is where
I was born and raised and then you have
Korea is is where I'm you know my blood
and my DNA and where I live now then you
have a heart and inside I think it says
family friends and music if I'm not
mistaken so art of movement is my b boy
crew and you know I still identify as a
b boy dancer it's where I basically got
my group of friends from basically what
started off my career because if I was
never a b boy if I was never a dancer I
would have never became a singer
basically and that's why you know I have
B boy life hop you know very grateful to
the hip-hop culture just because it gave
me everything I have right now so that's
kind of like a a salute and appreciation
for hip-hop and then on on on here you
got godon then you got strength strength
and Faith just cuz I do believe in God
and you have to have faith in order to
have hope and hope gives you strength to
you know get through whatever you're
going through or to achieve whatever you
need to achieve find that motivation and
then yeah this is kind of like another
one where it's like I was young young yo
like the world is in my hands like like
an ignorant I'm the type of
mentality so yeah I'm just like the
world in the palm of my hands and this
is all art from um a artist named Mina
Kuan tally did the tattoos but the the
actual like art came from Mina kuin this
one and this one and then yeah this is
another another one where it's like I
was a very big fresh prince of belir fan
when I was growing up and so I was like
fresh prins of s and that could be so or
Seattle and then on the back of my arm
right here it says live free if I'm not
must I haven't seen the tattoo in a
while cuz it's on the back of my arm
does it say live free the line inside
it's like my family's birth dates and
then I think it says always come proper
and that's kind of like another like
little was Theon like yeah need to
hustle and grind and always come proper
like that type of mentality and the lion
is like that mentality like Heart of a
Lion know I have to stay strong because
I am accountable for a lot of people I
run through companies I have a lot of
employees my family friends I do take
care of or support a lot of people and
so I can't can't be weak mentally that's
something like yo you you got this like
even though I feel overwhelmed sometimes
I have to remind myself like you got
this like you you know give my
self-confidence self
boost oh yeah so I say it's like passion
and then upside down it is pleasure yeah
you didn't know that right yeah passion
and pleasure yeah she was like yo like
there's this thing where if you read it
one way it can say something else and I
was like oh that sounds cool you
have to have passion but you also have
to enjoy things sometimes on this side
see no evil speak no evil do no evil
right and it's like Angels like I said I
I I do believe in God so I don't like
evil and I you know I think a lot of
people don't like evil but like there's
a lot of evil things in this world it's
very easy to get engulfed in that type
of stuff so you know I try to like
remind myself like to try to stay away
from that type of everything I get
is except for the piece from B which is
on my leg I wanted to get the aomg which
is another label that I founded and then
he finished so quickly he was like I got
another hour like you want to do
something I was like okay and then
so he did the other side of my leg and
he just freestyled that one so besides
that one everything else is just things
that I wanted to get yeah so it's aomg
artists Only Money Getters or like above
Ordinary music group it stems from a art
of movement my bber crew and then I
turned it into a label so he finished
this in like an hour and a half and then
he was like yo you want something else
and I was like oh cool and so he did
this so it's like a rose feathers
another mic some notes and a eye you
know I didn't ask particularly like why
I hated the eye but you know I was like
y you know he he's he just freestyled
this as well in an hour and a half so
that just goes to show how talented he
is he he did it like breathing almost I
have another piece I got it like 7even
eight years ago it's like an angel and I
haven't finished it yet so it's been
unfinished for like 7even eight years
and I don't think I'll ever finish it to
be honest well I'm not getting a lot of
tattoos anymore um but I I love my ink
and I still you know I'm am on TV so
it's all good
[Music]